welcome to Pixar in a box a
collaboration between Pixar Animation
Studios and the Khan Academy I'm Fran I
work here on the technical side of
things and I'm Alex
I work here on the art and storage side
of things Pixar in a box will introduce
you to some of the fundamental skills we
used to make our movies there's examples
of real-life film challenges that show
how an artist's idea can create a tidal
wave of technical creativity and how
technical advances can inspire artists
to think of new ideas to bring to the
screen you'll meet artists scientists
animators coders sculptors all kinds of
different people and a thing is most of
them use skills you may already be
learning in school but here in the box
you can see how we use those skills to
make cool stuff before you dive into
these lessons you should see how it all
fits together inside Pixar the real
Pixar come on check it out Pixar on any
given day we're working on various
stages of many films but it all begins
with an idea for example Toy Story
started with the notion that when kids
leave the room their toys come to life
and honestly I was convinced that my
toys did that
our films start in story along with the
director and the writer we figure out
what happens using simple drawings it's
kind of like a comic book exactly and
while we're drawing production designers
and their teams start designing the
world and the characters
while they're painting and drawing and
sculpting our storyboards go to
editorial where they string together all
the drawings that we've created we time
them out at music dialogue and sound
effects and as these shots go through
each stage and production will update
this scene over and over again and this
is where the science and the math come
in what's next
pipeline we're ready to start making the
film you'll see in the theater and this
happens in a particular order it's time
for our technical artists to figure out
how to create the movie in the computer
I've been here for nine years and I
still have no idea how you guys turn our
drawings into the finished film to be
honest
something stumped us on every movie Hey
Galen hey you've been here since Toy
Story what's been hard on each film
well Toy Story everything here let me
show you on Toy Story we were inventing
the entire process from scratch monsters
incorporated fur and clothing on cars
reflective metal surfaces on every new
film there's a new technical challenge
on inside out we had a deal with a
character made of glowing particles and
it took lots of people to figure out
just that one thing whoa what is she
made of her shape will be made of points
and particles of light she was tough
this is the 17th version and the
characters have to move so someone has
to add controls to the model like a
puppet right yes except instead of
strings our animators will use a
computer program to move the characters
in a digital world
next in the pipeline that's so for cars
too you've built the entire city of
London we need a huge chunk of the city
because mater and MacLean speed through
it so we figured out how to grow
buildings with enough variation for them
to look real and we move through that
set with our virtual cameras next up
animation I dunno what the animators do
they bring the characters to life you
see how she's moving but her clothes and
hair are missing adding and moving those
elements it's gonna be someone else's
job further down the pipeline
and by somebody else I mean me and about
20 other simulation technical artists
where are you getting all these shirts
we have to build everything you see
including the textures and surfaces
which help make the world and characters
believable next up lighting ironically
it's really dark in the lighting
department so when you start there are
no lights no any source of light is
something we have to add into the scene
in this shot alone there are 230 lights
last stop the render farm a film is
really a series of images or frames
there's 24 of them every second this is
where we make the frames everything
comes together here all the art math and
science a single frame can take more
than 24 hours to render and that's just
one frame and that's assuming we don't
run into any snags
[Music]
Wow it's incredible seeing final shots
and now that I know how they're made
even cooler so that's the tour the next
step is to jump back into the box and
choose a lesson what do you want to try
well this one I'm building robots using
combinatoric s-- that looks pretty cool
what about the one I'm petting staging
yeah are the one on animating The
Incredibles awesome always wanted to
animate